the Joe Rogan experience what is
disturbing both of you most about what's
going on right now well I think we'd
love to see a third way so they're the
pre-modern as it were who have a very
traditionalist concerned sucker up close
to you sorry that no worries yeah
perfect
the the pre-modern should have a very
traditional conservative approach to
gender roles to sex to relationship and
there are a lot of us in the modern
world who would reject a lot of that and
then there are the postmoderns who want
to throw out everything I want to throw
out everything that evolution handed us
and in the meantime pretend that it
didn't happen right pretend it's not
even based on reality and there is a
there's a third way and you know maybe
we need to call it modern as opposed to
pre or post modern but there's there's a
third way to navigate what evolutionary
is what evolution has given us what we
can change what we can't change and how
to actually recover some of you know the
sexiness and sex and the love and love
and the romance and romance and you know
understand that human beings are what we
are from not just a hundred years back
but a thousand and ten thousand a
hundred million years back we've had sex
since you both taught at a university
level you you've been around these
students and you've seen this sort of
post modernist movement gained steam
what what do you think is the cause of
it like what what is the reason why
people are projecting this sort of
distorted idea that there's no
differences between men and women and
that all the differences in the genders
are all it's all propaganda or cultural
or so I I think it actually arises from
a relatively simple cause that we all
detect there's something not right about
what we've been taught we detect there's
something not right about the way
civilization is structured we can tell
that there's nobody really at the helm
and you have a lot of people who are
faced with some issue that to them is
incredibly glaring something that just
ABS
needs to be solved and so what they do
is they look at that issue and they say
what would we have - what would we have
to say in order for that issue to be
fully addressed and the problem is that
we're dealing with a complex system and
if you optimize for any one solution you
cause a catastrophe across all of the
other things that it's connected to and
if you're not focused on those
unintended consequences you tend not to
understand why people are resistant to
your solution so for example let's deal
with the transgender issue for the
transgender community and I don't you
know this is not a model of the
community I actually know quite a number
of people within it who have a heterodox
position but in general there's a sense
that it is disrespectful not to simply
recognize anybody who has decided to
transition as a full-fledged member of
the sex to which they have moved that
seems right and if you are focused on
the humanitarian side of the question
maybe it even is right but the problem
is if you say a person who identifies as
a particular sex is that sex suddenly
you've actually caused a whole bunch of
consequences that you weren't thinking
of over in a biology class over in the
prison system I mean is it true that
somebody who says that they are female
gets to go to a women's prison do we
want to put violent sex offenders in a
women's prison because they declare
themselves to be female
so not tracking the consequences that
were not in your view when you decided
on a particular solution is the reason
that so many people have signed up for
these really absurd notions and part of
what I hope we will get to today is that
there is a a principle at the core of
understanding all complex adaptive
systems and it is diminishing returns
and diminishing returns sounds kind of
arcane it has to close an association
with economics where it was first
outlined but the
city of diminishing returns is that you
can very often get 90% of a solution
that you want and not disrupt other
things unduly but if you say I want a
hundred percent of the solution to this
problem you'll cause a catastrophe so
getting people to realize don't shoot
for the Utopia in which the problem
you're talking about is 100 percent
solved if you can accept a 90 percent
solution then you can have a whole bunch
of other things that you don't even
realize you're using in defense of
people that would try to go for a
hundred percent though isn't it one of
those things where like you if you would
negotiate you would if you want a
hundred dollars you ask for a hundred
and fifty
unfortunately I mean I think you're
identifying something correct that in
part the positions that we hear being
deployed are not an honest reflection of
the beliefs of many of the people who
are espousing them they're a negotiating
tactic but we can't do that with biology
you can't go she ate with biology
biology is what it is and then we can
talk about which parts of it are
amenable to being changed and as Heather
pointed out we're not advocating for a
return to some traditional way of
interacting between the sexes were
advocating for an enlightened way that
takes advantage of the freedoms we have
that our ancestors didn't and tries to
navigate the hazards that were stuck
with so you can't you can't negotiate
with biology you're really ought to
listen to what it is that nature is
telling you and then say alright what
does that leave open where can we shift
things but if you're going to require
that we lie about what's true
biologically in order to navigate to a
solution I guarantee you it will be
unstable in the end the zeitgeist has
begun to include such nonsense as
chromosomes exist on a continuum you
know there are X chromosomes and they're
like Roman heard that one one of our
children just heard that at his school
what did they mean by on a continuum no
I don't think they meant anything I
think what they intended to do was carve
out freedom from a biological truth and
so it
you say those ohms are on a continuum
then it's very hard to disagree with
that because it doesn't mean anything
that we can write a it's actually really
easy to disagree with it and say you
know you know gametes aren't on a
continuum sperm is sperm and eggs are
eggs sorry discrete two of them right
chromosomes also not a continuum at
least in mammals sex yeah a continuum
they're intersex is real but it's
strongly bimodal right there's there are
males and there are females and there
are a few people it's rare but real that
there are intermediate phenotypes and
gender is even more of a continuum but
still strongly bimodal have you folks
heard about that new crayfish that
they're battling in Europe there's a
giant crayfish in Europe that's female
and female only and essentially is a
clone they they reproduce by cloning so
they don't need a male partner and
they're going crazy and there's a lot of
create first two sentences there it
sounded like there was a and that's
gonna work for a while right in Lego
asexuality is actually evolved in a few
lineages a few vertebrate languages
there are some lizards that are asexual
and it's all females and it goes great
until the environment changes because if
you're cloning yourself you your
children academics perience exactly are
gonna be exactly the same thing that you
are so if you were a good fit for your
environment the next environment better
be the same or else your kids aren't
gonna be a good fit so my feeling is
that crayfish I haven't followed the
story a lot but that crayfish is going
to do terrifically moving into exactly
the landscapes that it first mutated
into existence and and if you change the
landscape a bit it's gonna stop doing so
I think they just farm it for food if
it's tasty yeah don't worry about them
breeding just get a ton of them together
crayfish are delicious they are
delicious
okay this is a good tasting variety it's
free food yeah you know I mean it's kind
of crazy
so Heather and I were talking before the
podcast started about I think a very
important point when it comes to a lot
of these either progressive or
right-wing issues is that people tend to
be extremely tribal and
what they're really concerned with is
winning it becomes a competition of us
versus them it becomes our side versus
their side and they tend to exploit
weaknesses and then attack to score
points and all ideas of being honest
intellectually or looking at things
objectively kind of go out the window
you ignore facts that diminish your
position or your team's position and
highlight things even if they're not
real that would diminish the other
side's position this is a real problem
that humans have with arguments with
with with being tribal with being on
different sides I mean we see it we
forget about tribes we see with people
where when there's a certain time when
you see people arguing there's a certain
point where the argument has
deteriorated to a competition and it's
no longer about what you're actually
discussing it's about who can win but
science is for yes yeah well this is
science ought to be indifferent when
it's done well it is indifferent to
who's the stronger team it should really
just tell you what's true and in fact
the reason to use Sciences to correct
for biases but so Erik and Heather and I
have a phrase that it's just shorthand
for something which is bad faith changes
everything there's a lot you can do in
discussion with people with whom you
disagree as long as you are on the same
page to a large extent yes and what
you're describing is what happens when
that system breaks down and people
perceive themselves as needing to win
against the enemy rather than on a team
that is trying to navigate to what is
true or what is the most desirable
outcome with respect to values that we
all share or something like that so what
you're describing is a very common state
it is a lower less capable state than a
good faith environment where people who
may disagree intensely agree on the
basic rules and the desirability of
figuring out what's true and so maybe
that's part of what we can do here is
try to point to where the good faith
conversation can get to that the bad
faith conversation
is incapable of getting to the value
really yeah I think that's that's a
giant point it really is and it's a I
mean if it's really something that I
would hope more people would adopt going
into the future stop connecting yourself
to these ideas and just let these ideas
exist on their own and examine them
objectively and rely on science rely on
actual science to formulate your when
you're talking about biological issues
when I say science is the answer to this
it's not necessarily that we should
accept no one should accept the findings
of science just at face value but a
scientific approach is I've got this
idea what would have to be true if that
were true and how can I possibly prove
it wrong and you work harder and harder
and harder to prove it wrong and if you
can't then you have greater and greater
and greater confidence that maybe it's
right and so this this is what we don't
see in bad faith arguments is no one is
trying to prove themselves wrong and
that's I mean that sounds backwards the
first time you hear it but if you try to
actually demonstrate that your own
cherished beliefs are wrong and you
can't do it
you have pretty good confidence at the
end of that and there is no actual end
but the longer you've gone you have
pretty good confidence that actually I'm
probably seeing something real here I've
asked myself I've asked my friends have
asked my enemies is this thing right and
you know in an actual formal scientific
setting you do an experiment you run the
data you do the analysis but is it right
or is it not let's see if I can prove
it's not even though I really think it
is so you also get tests you get
something there's a bonus that comes
with it which is I don't know what else
to say it's super awesome which is if
you've tried to take your cherished idea
some hypothesis that you've come up with
and you've tried 16 different ways to
show that it's wrong and you keep
failing well every one of those things
you did to see whether what you thought
was true is actually false now prepares
you when somebody now challenges you and
they say oh but you haven't thought of
this well you have you've been through
it 16 different ways and that gives you
the ability to navigate almost anything
that's thrown at you because
you have taken on the role of being your
own harshest critic in order to make
sure that what's left at the end of that
process is really robust the other thing
that I want to insert here is that I
think hey I don't want to be put in the
position of defending everything that's
been published in the scientific
literature as true because it looks like
science a lot of it isn't a lot of
what's published in the scientific
literature is not valid the methodology
does not establish what people claim it
does and that's a big hazard for for
people like Heather and myself because
you have to sort the wheat from the
chaff in order to figure out what to
defend and what to be agnostic about but
I do think those of us who more or less
get the story of what let's say human
sexuality is about at a scientific level
and there's still a lot of mystery but
there's an awful lot that those of us
who have studied it are in agreement
about and civilization is not yet on the
same page with those of us who have
looked at it scientifically one thing we
have failed to do I think is to
articulate what you will get in exchange
for signing up for a scientific
worldview on this topic people do not
realize that a scientific worldview is
actually the thing that empowers you to
navigate your own love life in an
intelligent way it will let you that's a
lot more fun than it sounds when you say
it that way
yeah it's well then you know they're
there all of these famous arguments
about unweaving the rainbow or you know
somebody challenged Fineman that he was
the kind of guy who would take apart a
flower and destroy its beauty in order
to figure out how it worked and this is
the true science will destroy beauty
right and it's true no it's not true
you will get a lot of value you will
waste less of your time on people that
you shouldn't be interested in if you
understand what game they're playing
even if they don't understand
[Applause]